they start they start looking around the
rest of the freezer they find uh like a
pair of human hands oh my God how big
were they does it say yeah I think
they're like
[Laughter]
[Music]
size I'm just going to tell you guys a
crazy story about um someone who bought
a house oh no all right oh [__] going
you all the Insight in this situation
we're looking at um what city is it
it's in Mesa County Colorado there's a
woman and a son that live in this house
they sell it and they leave they leave a
bunch of crap there that they don't want
to take with them like stuff they don't
want so they're like hey you can just
have all this to the new owner new owner
comes in sees how much crap is Left
Behind in the house so then they do like
an online listing to be like hey if you
guys want free stuff come get the free
stuff we don't want it so among all that
free stuff there's a deep freezer a
bunch of guys come over to take the free
oh God they um they look through it oh
it's just a bunch of like frozen meat
they uh start unpacking it I bet black
bag comes out and as they're taking the
bag
human a human head falls out of the bag
oh Dad I was wonder where the dad was
this whole time that's and then what did
they do they said we didn't do it we
that's how we found it they start they
start looking around the rest of the
freezer they find a like a pair of human
hands oh my God how big does it say yeah
I think they're like
size do you think they're saving it to
eat later no one knows yet there's no
other details as of now they don't want
to release anything because they don't
want the person's loved ones to find out
that their you know Dad or whatever Mom
or whatever died before you know they
don't want them final through the news
so they're just keeping everything quiet
but our job today is to find out how
this woman and son are
innocent why are they innocent though
maybe they got B from the other owner
they bought it from okay this is what
happened bought it from the other owner
that was like hey you want to just keep
all the [__] oh so it's like it's passed
down a whole house ago it's like one of
those scary movies if you open the
fridge you're cursed until you have a
new owner that opens the fridge oh
that's what it is keep selling the house
the house keeps selling originally it
was the mom and the son that left but a
son's never produced by a single mother
so who's the father yeah where he at I
think the job is to try and make sure
that they're in Jo where's his dead beat
dad that's where I'm leading to okay got
it the father where's he at in the
freezer no no
no innocent remember he is a
[__]
killer okay he's in jail for what
masturbating in
public that's be he did it a bunch of
times but they so they never suspected
this guy but he's a hoarder okay and
they're like good riddens now that this
is now [__] stuck in jail it gives us
the time to divorce [__] run away
from this nightmare I don't want to deal
with his trash this is all his [__]
we're going to pack up our bags and
leave wait who did the father murder one
of the people he jacked off in front of
his best friend one of the witnesses
some somebody one of the witnesses that
says I'm telling and they're like oh no
oh no no no no no that was his eighth
effect not telling anybody can you
imagine that's the yeah
somebody he's
like and they're like oh I'm [__]
telling and then they're like recording
and they're like no no no no don't tell
don't tell I'll go back to jail I like
the idea that like if you tell anyone
I'm going to do an even bigger
crime so so there's no guarantee that
the the dead head man is the father we
don't even know if it's a man oh it's
just a head it's just a head so far it's
up to you to decide size n you got to
construct a story like how I didly your
turn I feel like so like in Florida's
known for the crazy [__] I feel like
Colorado is known for like the secret
crazy [__] oh secret crazy Florida's
openly crazy like oh I like to [__]
drink piss yeah like they're just crazy
that's what Florida's known for and I
feel like I feel like Colorado is like
oh we're a perfectly innocent family we
would never do that and then they have a
centipede collection in the bathroom or
something like it's like drinking piss
having CED collection eating people
collecting centipedes but I feel [__]
weird do that closet crazy do you think
the mom they also kind of have smash
shootings all the time Colorado yeah
yeah we that's actually true huh they
got well they had the Callum by they had
the Batman one they had I definitely
think the mom and the kid are innocent
you do really how so well because like
if you were guilty why would you just
leave that evidence there for the next
home buyer to find and why did they wait
till escrow to finish cuz dumping is
expensive dude yeah why would they why
would you wouldn't you get rid of it if
you actually did it yes versus like if
you didn't know for some reason that it
was there cuz somebody else did it or
some way but more importantly why didn't
clear the house what a bunch of
douchebags they didn't clear the house
for the next owners that's why I think
they're they're guilty that's why you
think they're guilty I think they're
just dirty yeah I think they're [__]
I think they're just bad people you
think there's any chance that they could
be innocent probably like 85% chance
they're
innocent cuz they will be the prime
suspects at this point but it's a strong
15% that they did it there a strong and
it's and it's not just the Mom it's the
mom and her kid so like if they were in
on it the kid would have to know wa how
old is his kid yeah how old is a kid
maybe the kid's a [__] weirdo and
he's the one that did it it has
centipedes yeah yeah but remember the
house the house was so messy you had to
dig to get to that freezer so they
weren't eating people otherwise it'd be
in their regular fridge that's true
interesting yeah you know so it was they
obviously had no idea about it they
forgot about it unless they're like
serial murders and have done this as
like a a lifestyle and career for like
their entire life would did you remember
if you killed killed the body and put it
in a freezer that was so buried like
would you still know that you what if
what if single mom she's working all the
time it's the kid the boy he's just a w
wah boy and he just likes to go that's
really cuz like that [__] does happen
bro like he's Catch a Predator he's
trying to catch Predators cuz he's a kid
catching him killing him putting him in
the freezer making the world better
that's Co bunch of molesters in the but
why would he save the body parts yeah
well unless that's a way to just hide
the body that the dude who's dead was
jacking off in front of him and he's
like I'm going to tell and the guy's
like I'm going to commit a bigger crime
and he's like no I'm going to commit a
bigger
crime it's those movies where every time
they kill somebody they put like a latch
on their arm this is a badge of honor so
I want the heads of my enemies in my
freezer nice so if we're trying to solve
a crime we need to consider all options
right cast a wide net so so it could be
okay they just don't know their dad
killed them killed some guy and stuffed
them in the freezer or the mom and the
son did kill the person in the freezer
but they just been [__] all day they
forgot to get rid of the evidence the
mom and the son yeah that happens got
consider the widest you could get they
might be [__] so the prompt is not
about trying to make them innocent
anymore we're going to make them worse
human beings hey better scenario better
scenario um Mom you know she she has she
has a boyfriend oh boyfriend and he
comes in the house kicks it every now
and then but he's like you know what I
don't even like this [__] I don't like
her son and he may he's into some shady
stuff already he's like oh I have a
perfect place where I could hide a body
I could put it over here I can put it in
their freezer and just dip the [__] out
who the [__] am I you know what I mean
if they're hoarders they're for sure the
annoying neighbors right they probably
leave the garage open all the time so
probably one night some serial killer
was like I need a place to put a body
hey this person has the garage open I'm
sneak in bye isn't that a thing and
hoarders never have security cameras
yeah and some people leave their garage
doors open or what if what if the dad
was a Joe Rogan listener he because I
hear all these [__] benefits of the
cold plune I'm going just go in the
freezer and he just Frozen I'm going to
cut my hands off and put in a plastic
bag cut his hands off cut his head off
he's like this cold plung doesn't work
what do you guys think happen to the
rest of the body it's just hands and
head hands and head man they ate it they
ate it they had to eat it what else
would you do with it that's but don't
some people don't they don't they dump
body parts you know like a different
worldwide yeah they usually usually when
there's a dismemberment it's spread out
yeah but it's not at the scene of the
crime they don't leave a few I wonder
why they would save that those pieces
maybe they thought fingerprints you know
oh it might be the whole thing they
don't want the body to be identified
yeah because no but why leave it at the
place why save it why leave it at the
place of origin I guess you got to leave
it somewhere or find it I know it's not
her husband or boyfriend it's her dad oh
it's her dad maybe a shady Uncle her dad
was a a serial killer and she had no
idea because the garage was the man cave
and women never step into the man cave
allow so when she died she couldn't bear
it anymore cuz she's like my daddy of
all my life died of all her life all my
life I known you all my life my daddy
you died and I'm sad and I don't want to
be here anymore cuz the memories so then
she says I'm just going to leave and
well he has a lot of cool collections
these weapons and knives and things and
guns so just give it to somebody you you
know not knowing maybe because women are
kind of dumb when it comes to tools
maybe she didn't know trip wire booby
trap knives saws Gatling gun you know
all that put it together weapons expert
she was like guillotine in the corner
yeah oh Gatling what a World War II
collectible guy you know right guys in
their toys interesting Cavalry Weaponry
right [__] bucket acid [__]
chloroform bucket of acid chill bear
with the lid off all the signs like tarp
over tarp over tarp it's like all the
signs of a serial killer collections of
noes finger nails different sizes colors
this one scented a [__] map with
people and then like strings going on
all over the place I wonder if this is
also a good way let's say the murderer
is the person that came to get the
freezer and they just go ooh look look
what's in this freezer what the heck is
that that's kind of an interesting way
to cover your ass that's another one too
that'd be some blessed timing but if it
wasn't if it's not frozen I'd be like H
that looks thought out dude yeah how
Frozen was the head yeah was it like
true that looks that looks thought out
dude yeah looks it's been refroze a few
times yeah but that is kind of smart
let's say that you did a murder and you
had a head you couldn't get rid of it so
you go to a garage sale you buy like a a
World War II trunk or something and
you're like D hey this was in here
already but then now you're suspect
number one yeah because like if your
name is on the list now they know to
question you that's true you know you
better you don't want to hide in plight
they usually catch the people that are I
wonder what the who the person is that's
and you can't say they're on drugs
either cuz they went through a whole
home purchase process like that's a very
time intensive process exactly so they
could have just like oh head just popped
out of nowhere oh it's much easier
though if the kid and Mom's guilty cuz
it's like they did it they are yeah it
makes more sense that's why I think
they've been [__] dude the kid in the
mom there there does have to be some
weird variable because I'm still like if
they are guilty why the [__] did they
just like leave the evidence for the cuz
they're just [__] weird Hillbillies
dude they're just [__] each other and
just putting people maybe they
forgot that could be very true though no
you know who they killed they killed the
dad cuz then he's like my Dad's getting
in the way of me loving my mom and then
she's like she's like the only way I'm
going to get out of this [__] is is if
if this [__] is not alive and
and she was like she was like maybe if
you just like I don't know if you just
killed your dad then like we could [__]
yeah he go I've been thirsted for that
[__] since I was
born ever since I left I always wanted
to come back in taste it at once can't
forget yeah oh Anthony Lee the hell dude
Joe script writing I'm just reading the
table read right now we're doing the
table read he's helping me with a with
the with with the roles his words I'm
just a very good actor I just took
inspiration from Bart
story he's Bart said it's a love affair
I made it a triangle and I gave it
motive Bart's got the actual life story
because it's his real life he turned it
into a script and then I'm doing I never
[__] my mom great you should sell this
to Lifetime you're disgusting why would
you say that Bart you're a hero for
speaking Bart said they're in love yeah
so I was like they got to well if
they're in love how convenient they
killed the husband that's why Bart's
dad's not around right dude why you got
to hurt my
feelings that's the table read try to
cryy cry was molded by like what
everyone finds c yeah there you go now
we can put based on inspired by true
life
events I don't like this article I don't
like
this
[Music]